[موسيقى]
كيف يمكنك شرح
الحب الذي ذهبت إليه في 82 دولة عشت فيها
12 دولة ، لكنني جئت إلى هنا في تلك الأيام الثلاثة ،
شعرت للتو أنني في المنزل أحب الطقس البارد ،
أحب الثقافة التي أحبها التاريخ الذي
أعجبني كل شيء  حول هذا الموضوع
[الموسيقى]
لذا فإن الأشخاص الذين يستمعون إلى هذا مرة أخرى هو نوع
من التناقض لأنني بالفعل
وقواق كبير
وأفكر مثل الروسية ولكن
المكان يجعلك
[موسيقى
] اتخذت قراري بالمجيء إلى هنا
لأنني شعرت  وأدركت أن بإمكاني بناء حياة جديدة
فلاح روسي
[موسيقى]
أنا مهاجر إلى هذا البلد لكنني
روسي وهو
منزلي ولا يمكن لأحد أن يرى أي شيء سيء بشأنه ،
يجب أن ينظروا أولاً  في حد ذاتها
[موسيقى]
اليوم أنا أعيش هنا باللغة الروسية ،
يُطلق عليه اسم الممر
الفاصل بين عجلتي كوروفنيك اثنين من سقيفتنا
في هذه الغرفة في الواقع حيث
كانت معدات تشغيل الحلب هي المكان الذي بدأنا فيه
حياتنا الزراعية  الآن أكثر من 26 عامًا
إذا نظرت إلى السطح فهو
سقف  كوروفنيك عادي
ولكن هذا منزلنا
[موسيقى]
إيلينا
[موسيقى] لقد
جئت إلى هنا وأنا أتوقع أن جميع السوفييت
لديهم رقبة تأتي من آذانهم إلى
أكتافهم وأنهم في حالة سكر كان
هذا النوع من
الصور مثيرًا للاهتمام والناس بعد ذلك
البيريسترويكا
كان الجميع مضيافين للغاية لأنها
كانت حياة
رأسمالية جديدة لم تصل ، لذلك كان لدى الناس
المزيد من وقت الفراغ
ذهبت إلى حانتين عدت
واستقالت وقلت أنني أريد الذهاب إلى روسيا لقد
قفزت في هذه الفرصة
بسرعة كبيرة
لأنني كنت خائفًا من فقدانها ،
كان عمري 42 عامًا في
الوقت الذي شعرت فيه للتو بأنني في المنزل
[موسيقى]
روسيا
اليوم هي
[موسيقى]
كنت رجلًا حرًا ولكنني أعتقد أن الله قرر
ذلك  لن يكون هذا الرجل حرًا ، لذا في
غضون
ثلاثة أشهر كنت في حانة يوم الثلاثاء
، كنت رجلًا حرًا كنت أنظر عبره
وكانت هناك سيدة شقراء طويلة
وأعتقد أنني كنت سأشتري لها مشروبًا ، لقد
رجعت خطوة إلى الوراء
جون  كنت بطيئا
وقلت أوه أنا آسف جدا هل
تتحدث اللغة الإنجليزية  ish
وكانت إجابتها بالطبع قلت ، أنا آسف ، هل يمكنني شراء
مشروب لك وأعتقد بالطبع
أن هاتين الكلمتين الوحيدتين اللتين عرفتهما في ذلك الوقت
من
[موسيقى] أجنبية ،
تعرفنا على بعضنا البعض
بسرعة كبيرة  الكثير من الأسئلة
ولكن أسئلتي كانت بشكل أساسي ما
الذي فعلته عندما كنت صغيرًا وأيًا كان
لأن لدي هذه الصورة التي تعرفها هنا أنا
رجل أعمال دولي كل ما
سمعته عن هذه الحصص الغذائية الدموية
[الموسيقى]
هو
ألبوم وهناك وجدت صورًا لـ
شخص عادي و
13 ذاهبة إلى الشمال مع كلابها
تنزل إلى
المقاهي للتزلج وإقامة الحفلات مع
أصدقائها ، لقد صرخت
من العار تقريبًا لأن هذه الأم الأجنبية الرهيبة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى
]  أعطته مبلغًا معينًا من المال ،
فأخذه إلى بلد
تسمى باث وقال إنك لا تحب
روسيا تعيش هنا ،
أخذت جواز سفره الروسي وقلت
أراك عندما أراك
[موسيقى]
لم يفهمه الناس  أو
يمزح عنه وبعد ذلك  منذ سنوات بكى
على والدته ،
انضممت إلى الجيش ، وسأذهب إلى سيبيريا ،
وأريد العودة إلى المنزل ،
وكان اختياره
في عام 1997 بالطبع كان الجميع
يريد المغادرة
وقد جاء هذا الأحمق وأراد
العيش هنا
عندما تمت مقابلتي
لقد جاءوا إليّ في تلك الأيام
وقالوا لي جيدًا لماذا تريد أن تعيش في
روسيا ، قلت حسنًا بخير
، قالوا ألا تخاف من المافيا ،
قلت إنني حصلت على أفضل
كريشا وقالوا  لا يمكن لمن كان في
Gospelberg لدي إخوة وأخوات في المملكة
المتحدة وأعتقد أنه أزعجهم
جيدًا عندما أفترض أنني تحدثت إليهم
منذ بضع سنوات قالوا إن
أطفالنا سيقابلون جيدًا عند الحدود
إذا كان هناك نزاع إذا  يأتي الناتو
إلى الحدود ، ربما يكون
ابن أختي هناك وربما
ابنتي على الجانب الآخر منه ،
فهم لا يفهمون أنه
بصفتي إنكليزيًا ليس لدي ولاء
هناك ،
لدي الكثير من الغضب وخيبة الأمل.
لكي يفهم الناس أن
لديهم ديمقراطية ح
انظروا إلى الحرية ، انظروا إلى ما تفعله الحرية اليوم ، إنها
قريبة من الفوضى ،
الحرية هي الحق في قول ما تريد
ولكن ليس تدمير أي شيء
[موسيقى
] بالطريقة التي يشوهون بها ونستون تشرشل ،
ليس لدي أي فكرة ،
أعتقد أنه غبي ، أعتقد أنه
لا أساس له
تاريخ العواطف هو تاريخ وربما
تذكرنا هذه النصب التذكارية بما
لا يجب فعله ،
أعني حسنًا أننا نعلم أنه كان هناك عبودية إذا
لم يكن هناك أي عبودية
لن يكونوا في أمريكا ، إنه أمر منافق بعض الشيء
بالنسبة لي ماذا كان ما
يمكنك
يعد التاريخ درسًا ولكن يجب أن
تفهمه ، يجب أن تدرس أي شخص
يريد أن يكون
ثقافيًا يجب أن يفهم التاريخ ليس
فقط لبلدهم من العالم ككل
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
أعتقد أن الحظر
بالنسبة لنا كان جيدًا جدًا ، وأعتقد أنه
سمح للناس أولاً باستعادة
كبريائهم لكونهم روسيين
قبل أن نفقده نوعًا ما ،
واليوم أعتقد
أن لدينا الحظر المفروض عليهم أنهم لا يفعلون ذلك
.  ر عقوبات ضدنا  لأنهم
فقدوا أكثر بكثير "
نعم"
[موسيقى]
أجنبية لا أحب السيد جون. لا أحب عمي
جون ، اسمي الأوسط الحقيقي هو ماكسويل
حيث أتت ليس لدي أي فكرة
تعرفها في الغرب في  المملكة المتحدة ، تسمي
الاسم الأوسط لابنك بعد فريق كرة قدم ،
فهذا ليس له
معنى وأيضًا بالنسبة لي ، هذا أمر مهم
هنا يتعلق باحترام والديك ،
وأعتقد أنه
هذا استمرار من أين أتيت
من هنا
الاسم الأوسط الذي تأخذه  أبي ،
أنا جون جانيش ، مما يعني أنني
ابن جان وأنا فخور جدًا به
[موسيقى]
نحتاج إلى
[موسيقى
] يجب حفرها هنا
يجب تنظيف الأنبوب وهذا  قناة
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
محتلة
أجنبية
عندما طلبت من نينا الزواج مني
قالت سأفكر في الأمر أنني بحاجة للتحدث
إلى كاهني فقلت إنني أؤمن بالله ليس لدي
مشكلة أنا أبحث  من أجل الله حتى يتم
تعميدنا وذهبنا إلى كنيسة vivanvoynon
Lininski وقد تم تجريدي من الملابس وأعطيت
قميصًا أبيضًا وفتاة
منذ خمسة عشر عامًا ، بدأنا في بناء
هذه
الكنيسة باسم السيدات اللائي
وجدن
المسيح ونمزح حول ذلك لأنه في اللغة
الروسية هو جان
ميرونوسيتس وعندما سمعت هذا اعتقدت أنه
جون ميرانوسيس ما هو بحق جون
ميرانوسيس ماذا يفعل هذا  يعني ولكن في
الحقيقة إنها سيدات المر
[الموسيقى]
كنت أؤمن دائمًا بالله ولكن
الكنيسة الكاثوليكية أخافتني بصدق
، وباللغة الروسية لدينا هذه الكلمة ضربت
بورجا الخوف من الله وعندما كنت
كاثوليكية كنت أخشى الذهاب  إلى
الكنيسة شعرت في كل مرة كنت أذهب فيها إلى
الكنيسة وأقول شيئًا غبيًا سيصيبني
الصاعقة
[موسيقى
] وأنا أحب الاعتراف الروسي هنا ، فأنا
أحب أشياء كثيرة في روسيا
ونقص النفاق
لا أعتقد  يجب أن أبرر سبب
اعتقادي بأنه حتى لو
لم تكن مؤمنًا ، فإن الوصايا العشر ليست
قوانين سيئة يجب على الجميع أن يعيش بموجبها
اليوم
[موسيقى
] أحب بيتي هنا وأعتقد أن
أي شخص يريد  للمجيء إلى هنا ،
سيتم الترحيب بك بصدق ، فهذه
ليست دعاية ، فأنا لم أجر مقابل ذلك
لحسن الحظ ، ولسوء الحظ ، إنها
دولة رائعة لها آفاق شاسعة ، وأحب
الآفاق الشاسعة
، وأينما كان هناك أفق ضخم ،
هناك دائمًا إمكانات ،
كنت روبوتًا عندما أتيت  كنت هنا
رجل أعمال دوليًا رأسماليًا نموذجيًا
أسافر تسعة أشهر في السنة وأنام
أربع ساعات في الليلة ،
لذا فقد خلق هذا رجلاً أجمل كثيرًا
أعتقد
أنني سعيد بالطبع أنا سعيد لأنني لم أفكر مطلقًا في
أنني سأصبح 70 عامًا لم
أفكر أبدًا  كنت أرى ابنتي الصغرى تبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا ،
لذا فقد منحني الاندفاع حياة طويلة وكذلك
لدي كل ما أريده ، لكن حلمي الوحيد
هو أن يجد جميع أطفالي
نفس النوع من السعادة التي فعلتها
[موسيقى]
أنت